Дебютне засідання Верховноїрішен Ради пройшло, так би мовити, на "п’ятій швидкості".
Власне, як цього й бажав президент Володимир Зеленський.
Я впевнений, що зараз Україна
нарешті зможе увімкнути п’яту швидкість
і впевнено рухатися шляхом змін.
Я дуже радий, що у нас з’явився парламент,
який готовий дійсно працювати.
Депутати розійшлися лише о другій ночі,
пропрацювавши фактично16 годин і ухваливши низку важливих рішень.
Новим прем’єр-міністром України за поданням президента Зеленського
Верховна Рада затвердила Олексія Гончарука.
Перед голосуванням у своєму виступі з трибуни 35-річний юрист
пообіцяв українцям дешеве кредитування, нову трирічну програму співпраці з МВФ
та боротьбу з корупцією.
Ми досі не впоралися з тим,
що хтось приходить до влади для того, щоб щось "пилити".
У новому уряді ніхто красти не буде.
Також за поданням Зеленського Верховна Рада затвердила
міністром оборони України Андрія Загороднюка, який анонсував найближчим часом
презентацію об’ємної програми розвитку Збройних сил України.
А міністром закордонних справ призначили Вадима Пристайка,
що Україна збереже курс на ЄС та НАТО.
Решту міністрів депутати призначали за поданням вже новообраного прем'єра Гончарука.
За склад нового уряду проголосував 281 нардеп.
Найбільш скандальним стало повторне призначення Арсена Авакова -
однієї з набільш суперечливих фігур минулого Кабміну -
міністром внутрішніх справ України.
Верховна Рада підтримала пропозицію Зеленського
призначити новим генеральним прокурором Руслана Рябошапку.
Той пообіцяв "перезавантаження й оновлення системи"
і переатестацію в органах прокуратури.
А новим головою Служби безпеки України
депутати затвердили соратника Зеленського Івана Баканова,
який до старту своєї політичної кар’єри очолював студію "Квартал 95".
Баканов анонсував новий закон про СБУ, який усуне
деструктивну конкуренцію між правоохоронними органами
і пообіцяв "життя за законами, а не понятіями".
Обіцянка - цяцянка: стара Рада п’ять років обіцяла, але так і не зробила.
Після опівночі після палких дебатів новий парламент
у першому читанні схвалив скасування депутатської недоторканності.
Це, можна сказати, історичне для України рішення
підтримали 363 народні депутати.
Жодного голосу проти не було. В разі остаточного ухвалення
закон має набути чинності з 1 січня 2020 року.
Оновлена Верховна Рада складається з 5 фракцій та однієї депутатської групи.
Найбільша фракція - "Слуга народу", там 254 нардепи,
які і сформували монобільшість. Найменша - "Голос" із 17 депутатами.
Спікером очікувано став голова партії "Слуга народу" Дмитро Разумков.
Народні депутати затвердили керівництво та склад парламентських комітетів.
Їх у новій Раді 23 - на чотири менше, ніж у попередній.
І тут теж, по суті, монобільшість:
19 з 23 комітетів очолили "Слуги народу".
Найбільше запитань викликав Нестор Шуфрич від "Опозиційної платформи - За життя"
як голова комітету свободи слова.
Перший млинець нанівець - цього про перший день
Верховної Ради 9-го скликання не скажеш.
Президент Зеленський дав парламенту на продуктивну роботу один рік –
такий собі випробувальний термін.
Мовляв, у разі чого він уже має досвід розпуску Ради,
і це, за його словами, не так страшно.